from the worldwide leader in sports to
maybe put a little bit more meat on the
bones of her tweet that came out this
morning
that uh julio jones trade is
a foot to say the least from the
worldwide leader in sports
diana russini how are you diana hi
rich 99 of the time i envy you i want to
be you i want to live where you live
okay but right now in new york this is
the place to be
so i can officially say it is much
better
in manhattan than it is in manhattan
beach okay um
let's let's uh let's go there first i
didn't think we'd
we'd go anywhere other than the julio
jones trade first but
you opened the door what what's so great
the knicks win a playoff game or
i don't get it like what's so great
about my hometown
right now i just can't remember the last
time new york felt
this alive i mean i know we're excited
as
a city to just have a little covered
normalness that feels a bit with
restaurants and bars open and no one's
wearing masks walking outside it's been
beautiful weather
but to actually be able to be proud
to be a knick fan to want to wear orange
again a color that looks terrible
on most people but now
uh with my tan the orange is all i'm
wearing for the next month
so i mean you might disappear with your
tan uh and some wearing art
so you're from the bronx right is that
where you're from
i'm originally from the bronx but i grew
up most of my life
in new jersey um so that's why my can is
it orange has been a while since even
the discussion of madison square gardens
being electric
the last time it was electric it was in
a movie you know that adam sandler
probably did like 15 years ago i can't
even recall
so it look i'm not really trying to make
you that jealous just no
slightly uh but the city the city's
hopping and it's good
well it's great i mean and then maybe
you should help me with this diana since
you're
you have such a sunny disposition as
you've already established and
and you also resemble the the uh yellow
orb or orange orb in the sky
um as you've just established i just
can't get past the fact that i hate
james dolan so bad and that this makes
him happy
and that i i i don't know i i know i'm
gonna have to let this go at some point
in time
but you know the fact that we're not all
one big happy organizational family like
oakley's not on board i can't be on
board you know what i mean like it's
it's very difficult
for me to separate the two winning cures
all they say that
and i haven't experienced it here in new
york in a while
uh it is incredible how much you can put
past
put your hate in the back pocket get a
little
taste uh of what this feels like so i i
hear you on the
on the dolan stuff this has been going
on forever i know that but
uh for now let's try to enjoy this okay
okay
[Music]
put your hate in your back pocket is a
very nice way to go about this it also
sounds like a nice jingle
put your hate in your back pocket and
just smile when julius randle passes off
to taj gibson i got it
i will do that how does that sound diana
it sounds
wonderful okay very good thank you for
helping me with that now help me with
the the julio jones trade i have diana
rossini here on the rich eisen show your
tweet
um certainly caught my eye today that
the
falcons have discussed several trade
offers for julio jones including an
offer
for a future first round draft pick and
uh go for it what what uh what can you
tell me about this
yeah let's start with right around the
draft
the the buzz began and and that's when
it really got out uh the falcons had
been doing work
over the phone probably since early
march
uh when they started to to put it out
there that hey
we're open for business they had a few
teams they had some interest
the price they wanted not great at the
time not bad just not what they were
looking for
what they're looking for a first rounder
over the last three four days it's
really started
to heat up uh the traditional thing that
we've seen these days with quarterbacks
reaching out
to their potential new receivers or new
star players has
begun quarterbacks from big teams big
star players have
started to call julio the recruitment
has begun
but as we know it always comes down to
what's going to be the value what is the
trade value
atlanta wants a first rounder and they
seem pretty
um stuck on that they're not willing to
wiggle as of now
and they have an offer on the table from
a team from what i've been able to
gather
late last night and early this morning i
think
sometimes when you hear reports like
this you immediately think well
obviously that's atlanta telling her
this because they want the price to go
up
um but the initial
information i actually received was from
another team who was interested which
then made me do some work on it
uh because this team was does not have a
first rounder available
or at least they're not willing to give
it up for julio and they were pretty
bummed to hear that
the chances of landing him were were
decreasing so here we're at
here we are at uh and i think it it's
heating up rich i think this is
something that we can see go down over
the next few weeks here
and so um this is uh born
out of um out of i guess the salary cap
necessity um or or the fact that julio
apparently asked for a trade according
to my colleague at the
nfl media group in ian rappaport months
ago what what
why now is it the june 1st
ability for atlanta to not take the
biggest cap hit possible as opposed to
the draft is that why we're seeing the
timing
right now diana racine very much so rich
that is the reason
and look it's a little
you we could probably split hairs on
what really went down in terms of
was this julio asking for a trade first
or was this
the falcon open to training him um
the way i gathered the information since
i started hearing about this a few weeks
ago or actually a few months ago
it was atlanta was open to training and
then julio found out about it and then
that's how that began
so and look it really doesn't matter
obviously both sides just aren't happy
they don't want it
they don't want to be together so after
this june first date it makes the most
sense
and it's something that's going to most
likely happen and it and
it all works out as it sounds like it is
right now
atlanta could walk away with a first
round draft pick for a 32 year old wide
receiver
that would be remarkable uh but it's not
just any 32 year old wide receiver
either i guess so
name me some teams that you're hearing
that would be
um the landing spot here for julio jones
diana well there's a big difference
between the teams that are offering the
first round
the future first round graphic obviously
and those that are interested
um the names that i've been hearing over
the last week or so
the new england patriots uh the
tennessee titans have been talking
to atlanta as well um i have not heard
if it was those teams that have
been willing to come up um the sense i'm
getting is
that price is too high the san francisco
49ers the baltimore ravens
priced too high is what i keep hearing
from those
teams so those are the ones i've been
able to check in with to confirm
are in but may not have the right value
right now for that trade to go down but
um again i think just historically when
you look back the past 25 years
11 receivers have been traded for at
least one first round traffic
of those randy moss and joey galloway
and they were both 28. yeah and they
both went to uh new england too right
i mean well wound up in new england at
one point
obviously um so um diana russini of espn
here on the rich eisen show
so we've established that julio jones is
it looks like this thing's about to
it's popping like th this is the sort of
stuff you need to hear before june 1st
you need to hear it the week before june
1st
in order for this thing to actually
happen and and
uh we're seeing it you're hearing it and
and now we're seeing it
so uh a team that i think would be uh
you know a great landing spot for him
and would help
fix everything um for everybody involved
if atlanta is looking for cap relief and
they're also
in this draft did not get the successor
to matt ryan
who they still eventually will have to
get uh and then there's another team
that does have
a young quarterback whose presence irks
the mvp quarterback that's on the pro
roster just
not because of his personality but
because we heard
that uh on on monday night that there's
a certain
culture that uh people don't get
respected in
why not the packers is what i'm saying
with aaron rodgers
and the falcons and jordan love going
there
with the two and everybody gets what
they want
and we move forward what about that idea
because the cap could be
massaged by green bay to make it work
yeah i think we both know we can they
can make these
the salary cap work for anybody um i'm
unfortunately learning that
the longer i'm doing this as a reporter
because that used to be my debate on
everything well they don't have the
salary because they don't the room they
know the room
and every gm is like stop saying that
you sound very dumb on television
um figure learn what really goes down
that's
all uh pretend so to speak but look
green bay has never been one
to hop in on stuff like this they've
shown interest in other receivers in the
past that have
heard over the last during the off
season and even during the season
um but i think the problem with green
bay right now is
moving forward i don't know if they know
what is happening
what what's the reality of who is going
to be under center and
we're seeing aaron look happy in love
perhaps maybe over sharing i think
something we all do while we're in love
um on social media right now and clearly
sending a message rich that
you guys are all sweating this you're
all watching me on every interview
uh we know matt leflore uh probably
watched the kenny main interview once if
not twice
to make sure just to see the tone the
feel
is there hope for them um and as i
continue to talk to people around the
league
it's not improving there isn't one thing
green bay can do do i think they could
put together a couple
big moves to make him happy maybe
but i don't know if i don't know trading
for julio jones
fixes all of this yeah i know this could
be everything
i know because the the we don't know
what the everything is but to say to
aaron rodgers okay
you wanted certainty financially that
might
translate into the certainty that you
could finish here
under your own terms how about finishing
here with the greatest wide receiver
tandem in the nfl
if not for the in the nfl for this uh
this century that's now 21 years old i
mean devonte adams and julio jones all
right aaron you wanted
you wanted this big bobby tonyan we put
aaron jones a little bit on the credit
card too
you know uh i know you wanted jake
kumaro but how does julio jones sound
instead you know like to me that would
be the wet kiss
publicly to say you know um
come back from hawaii let's go i mean
don't you think that would be the way to
go
in a way is the front office part of the
trade
are they going well i mean the front
office would be the one to pull it off
and
because the front we all know the way
this works there's no way
mark murphy's going to throw his general
manager overboard for anybody
like that's just it it's even for aaron
rodgers
like and and and so would that really be
helpful
that rogers now goes into his final
window of trying to win in green bay
saying i run the organization here and
then own like everything
i i don't know i mean i'd rather take
julio jones if that's my gambit
if i'm aaron rodgers and i know this is
pure potential fantasy football talk
when it all comes down to it but
you know there's a lot of time between
now and june 1st for us to fill
be very honest you know what i'm saying
and then there's certainly there's a lot
of tentacles to this you know i had a gm
not in that division um just having cut
look
everyone every team right now is
watching this
one because it's so interesting and i
think everyone
is putting themselves in the shoes of
green bay
putting themselves in the shoes of aaron
rodgers to try to
see what would i do in this case what
would you do to the gym what would you
do if you were matt before
um and so i i just had one gm share this
with me
he said you know i think green bay may
have more
leverage than what we're really giving
them credit for when you look at this
right because the league mvp is
miserable he wants to get traded okay so
let's just say they trade him he's not
on the team
but what if they don't trade them and
they keep him on the team
and aaron rodgers takes out a hard line
fans on this and says
i i'm gonna sit out and eat you know
what 45 50 million dollars because he'll
get a signing bonus taken away as we
know and
you know what whatever numbers it's a
lot right um and get that all
next year it gives green bay
the same result they don't have the
league mvp
playing for them but what they do now
have is time
time to do some work on these future
drafts
picks time to communicate with other
teams and perhaps get a better deal
and i just thought that was interesting
perspective from a from a different uh
organization but also just something i i
didn't hear a lot about
yeah i guess again you know uh put it
all
together and you know for me
getting julio jones on the team would be
a way to fix it and then the other way
around of course the general managers
around the league are
are keeping an eye on this too because
green bay
would be a far worse team and less of a
threat to win a super bowl this year
without aaron rodgers and whichever team
that aaron rodgers would wind up on
would not be as great a super bowl
threat
as green bay would be with aaron rodgers
because it's a new system and
you know the opportunity of him to win
in the first year we just saw what a
lightning strike lottery ticket that is
and it did hit for tampa
but i don't know if like denver or other
places
uh would be that spot like tampa i don't
know if
denver's is ready made to win as tampa
uh
was i so i i yeah i mean like
i'd be i'd be rooting for i'd be rooting
for aaron to force a trade too
it's always a gm yeah you know and maybe
i'm being a little bit um you know a
butterfly of optimism for you
on this thursday but i i do look at
the packers right now and what this
coaching staff can do
with the opportunity that they have with
jordan love and aaron not being there
and look i know the receivers aren't
showing up in practice right now and
that that only hurts the team but jordan
loves getting all these first game reps
he's getting you know some of that
experience getting in and out of the
huddle he didn't do anything he didn't
have
any of this last season you have to be
even playing a game so
if they can figure out a way to maybe
get this young
quarterback going maybe there's their
answer he's not aaron rodgers we're not
going to debate this right we know this
we all know the answer
but as they continue to say he's a long
ways away well
now it's their time to try to figure out
how to get them caught up
because aaron's not there it's a
distraction and right now the only
answer you have in front of you
is him and blake bortles i know thanks
for the time diana i really appreciate
it you uh
enjoy the rest of your day thank you
guys thanks for having me on
that's the butterfly of optimism telling
me to put hate in my back pocket for me
dianna rossini everybody hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here